[Music]
a new star wars movie is always going to
generate a certain amount of hype
but the upcoming final installment on
the skywalker saga may just be the most
anticipated film in the franchise yet
he has everything you need to know about
star wars the rise of skywalker
the first trailer for episode 9 revealed
that the film was titled the rise of
skywalker but that was just one of
several surprises that the teaser had in
store
the opening shots find rey showing off
her new abilities and a standoff with a
tie fighter on a desert planet that is
likely persona
a new location revealed by the coverage
of a set visit by vanity fair
finn and poe also get in on the action
and there's also a cheeky shot of the
droid dio bb8's new companion but one of
the biggest takeaways from the first
trailer comes as a stinger at the end
despite having been thrown to a
seemingly certain death by darth vader
in 1983's return of the jedi it seems
that emperor palpatine is somehow coming
back
the episode 9 trailer ends with a shot
of the death star's wreckage and
palpatine's unmistakable cackle
implying that the rise of skywalker will
see a new generation of heroes facing
off against the dark lord of the sith
palpatine actor ian mcdermid also
appeared on stage at star wars
celebration 2019 immediately after the
big trailer reveal
essentially confirming his involvement
in the movie
like the force awakens and the last jedi
before it the rise of skywalker is
hitting cineplexes worldwide in december
the trilogy kappa was originally
scheduled to be released in may 2019
but a series of destabilizing changes
behind the scenes made that target
unattainable
not long after disney removed directors
phil lord and chris miller from solo a
star wars story
and sidelined gareth edwards on rogue
one in favour of rewrites and reshoots
supervised by tony gilroy
colin trevaro was also fired from the
rise of skywalker
according to the wall street journal
lucasfilm president kathleen kennedy
considered bringing the last jedi
director ryan johnson back for episode
nine at one stage but the powers-up b
ultimately opted for the steady hand of
jj abrams instead
the rise of skywalker will be released
on december 20th 2019 in the united
states
although many overseas fans will get to
see the film a little sooner
the uk australia brazil and argentina
are all getting the movie on december
19th
while residents of italy france norway
and sweden can see the movie a day
earlier than that
you probably won't be surprised to learn
that daisy ridley john boyega
and oscar isaac are returning they're
the heroes of the sequel trilogy after
all but they'll be joined by a whole
host of faces
both familiar and new for fans of the
original trilogy
one of the biggest moments of the
episode 9 trailer was seeing lando
calrissian back in the cockpit of the
millennium falcon
the hollywood reporter revealed that
billy d williams was reprising the role
in july 2018
but details of lando's parts and the
rise of skywalker were kept under wraps
in the months that followed many now
believe that naomi aki who is playing a
new character named janna will be
revealed as lando's daughter during the
film
the up-and-coming british actress was
asked about this at star wars
celebration 2019
and her non-committal answer only served
a few rumors that she's a member of the
carissian family she told ign
lando is a very charming man so he could
have children all over the universe
that's all i'm saying you look
absolutely beautiful
you truly belong here with us among the
clouds
dominic monaghan of lust and the force
awakens greg grundberg
also both have roles in the rise of
skywalker and they aren't the only
abrams alumni appearing
mission impossible 3's kerry russell is
also playing a new master antagonist by
the name of zory bliss
one theory that's gained a lot of
traction following the release of the
rise of skywalker's first trailer posits
that the title isn't actually referring
to any single character
a number of people now believe that the
word skywalker will become a term
used to describe members of a brand new
order one that is at peace with both
sides of the force
as inverse puts it these people from rey
to kylo ren
to that little stable boy with the broom
at the end of the last jedi will not be
jedi or sith they will be skywalkers
comments made by the rights of skywalker
director j.j abrams seem to support this
theory
as celebration 2019 abrams told fans
this movie is about the new generation
what they've inherited the light and the
dark and that's the question about
facing the greatest evil
are they ready in may 2018 a reddit
poster with an impressive track record
when it comes to star wars spoilers
claim to have seen what was described as
a very early storyboard for episode 9.
this alleged production art began some
five years after the events of the last
jedi and it seems that
in that time kylo ren has managed to
hoodwink the entire galaxy
the user wrote kylo ren's rule over the
galaxy as seen by moses benevolent
many within the resistance itself are
questioning why they should even be
fighting
the post came hot on the heels of john
boyega teasing that finn would have a
new hairdo in episode 9. he told yahoo
i can't wait to start shooting the next
and final leg of the franchise
the first step is growing up my hair so
you can wait for the trailer to see why
this all but confirmed that the story
will catch up with finn and the
surviving members of the resistance
sometime in the future
but will five years really have passed
that's what those early spoilers claimed
but according to an article in empire
it's not exactly the case
in its official 2019 preview the
magazine stated
john boyega has confirmed episode 9
takes place one year after the events of
the last jedi
so while a time jumper may be in effect
it also might not be that drastic
after purchasing the rights to star wars
for more than 4 billion dollars in 2012
disney decided to clean house in a big
way when it comes to the series canon
prior to the release of the force
awakens the company declared that all
expanded universe materials
essentially anything that wasn't
depicted in the franchises movies or
television shows were no longer
considered to be official star wars
canon the mouse house then set about
creating its own line of short stories
comics and books to tie in with the new
continuity
and one such release in the new expanded
universe might just include a huge clue
about a major development for an episode
9 character in the 27th issue of the poe
dameron comic series
a conversation poe house with ray and
finn seems to confirm that he's been
unwittingly channeling the force all
this time
marvel's poe dameron comics overlaps
with jj abrams of force awakens
issue 26 explained how dameron survived
that crash on jakku
and filled in what he did between then
and rescuing ray and finn from the first
order
but it was the following issue that
really got readers talking in that story
dameron admits that he's been able to
tap into some kind of energy while
flying
prompting both rey and leia to suggest
he's been using the force
the seas of this reveal were actually
planted in the 2015 series star wars
shattered empire this prelude to the
force awakens explains how luke
skywalker gave remnants of a force
sensitive tree to damron's parents
who used them to grow a new tree at home
on yavin iv damron even mentions growing
up around this tree
further foreshadowing his connection to
the force during the last jedi yoda
showed up as a force ghost to help
troubled former students luke skywalker
come to his senses and
embrace his failures a standout moment
in the sagas divisive eighth episode
yoda was rendered in cgi for the prequel
trilogy but johnson chose to go back to
basics and brought in frank oz
to operate a slightly updated yoda
puppet creature designer neil scanlon
said
we just felt that it was absolutely
right and proper that we create the
puppet and the closest likeness to the
original and to give frank exactly what
he had the first time around
renowned puppeteer ours who provides
yoda's distinctive voice as well as his
movements
could also soon be adding episode 9 to
his impressive resume
if a new report is to be believed
according to the new york daily news
a source with apparent knowledge of the
production has revealed that jj abrams
is going to bring force ghost yoda back
the insider said the success of the
scenes featuring yoda in the last jedi
were huge
yoda will again appear as a ghost as he
acknowledges rey's success
and growth as a jedi lucasfilm's
original position on carrie fisher's
inclusion in future star wars movies
were pretty clear
she wouldn't be appearing in any before
the release of the last jedi kathleen
kennedy told abc
sadly carrie will not be in episode 9.
the idea that they could digitally
render a version of fisher like they did
with peter cushing's tarkin in rogue one
was quickly ruled out after execs met
with fisher's daughter billy lord
all parties reportedly agreed that it
would be disrespectful
at the time bringing leia back with
unused footage from the last jedi was
also said to have been off the table but
things have shifted since then
disney has since confirmed that fisher
will indeed be in episode 9
with jj abrams apparently set to use
footage shot for both the last jedi and
the force awakens
according to abc's clayton sandell who
spoke to carrie fisher's brother todd on
podcasts the resistance broadcast
the family are very happy about what
abrams has planned
wait a minute where'd she go bring her
back play back the entire message
the idea of darth vader returning to the
big screen in episode 9 might seem
ludicrous on the surface
but it seems disney has been subtly
paving the way for the iconic sith lord
to play some part in the upcoming
installment
after reading marvel's darth vader
comics which chronicled the villain's
first years working under the emperor
screen rant noticed once more detail
that could be foreshadowing a future
appearance in the movies the inn's
announce of becoming a force ghost have
been up for discussion among star wars
fans ever since luke skywalker
passed on in controversial fashion at
the end of the last jedi the assumption
was that returning as a force ghost was
something only those in tune with the
light side of the force could do
but shouldn't the sith have their own
version of this phenomenon turns out
they do
and it was explained in the pages of the
vader comic in the story in question
vader is gifted a mask that once
belonged to another powerful sith called
darth marmon
marmon's residue was still attached to
the artifact when palpatine gave it to
his third and final apprentice
who used it to help erect his castle on
mustafar the forgotten sith was able to
influence others and tell his story to
vader via the mask
screamrun's prediction is that vader
will similarly influence proceedings in
episode 9
seeing as his grandson kylo ren is in
possession of vader's half-melted mask
the backlash that ed sheeran received
following his game of thrones appearance
ought to put him off cameos for life
but if rumors circulating in the british
press are to be believed
the award-winning singer-songwriter has
gone on to film a scene for episode 9-2
shiron abandoned his twitter account
after ira's game of thrones fans told
him exactly what they thought about him
popping up as a lannister soldier in the
season 7 opener
luckily for shiron fans won't be able to
spot his mystery scene in the upcoming
star wars installment
because his famous red hair will be
hidden by a stormtrooper's helmet
dan walton executive editor of the sun
confirmed i can reveal the world's most
successful male singer has been suiting
up for scenes to appear in episode 9
which has been filming at pinewood
studios since august sheeran won't be
the first famous englishman to don the
iconic white uniform on the sly
daniel craig snuck into the force
awakens as a stormtrooper in a scene
with rey
and princess william and harry were in
the last jedi though their scene only
made the home version as an added extra
according to london's evening standard
the royals were cut out of the final
movie because they were just too tall to
be stormtroopers
with appearances and doctor who and game
of thrones under his belt veteran
character actor richard e grant already
had some major fan cred when he was cast
in the rise of skywalker
as it turns out he's a big star wars fan
by himself on the podcast happy sad
confused the actor opened about the
moment jj abrams told him it'd be a part
of the final chapter in the skywalker
saga
and revealed how he was so excited that
he couldn't actually take anything in
for a time the most popular theory was
that grant will be taking on the role of
grand admiral thrawn
a popular expanded universe villain
reintroduced into canon in the third
season of star wars rebels
but the actor outright debunked that
rumor when the radio times asked him
about it when vanity fair released a
huge episode 9 cover story in may 2019
the identity of grant's character was
finally revealed he's playing a new
villain named allegiance general pride
that's the magazine reported the oscar
nominee promised us to bring on-screen
menace and off-screen clay
most fans didn't love the fact that the
last jedi neglected to include the
knights of ren a team of warriors first
teased in the promotional materials for
the force awakens
kylo ren's band of fighters appear
briefly when rey touches luke
skywalker's lightsaber
and triggers a force vision but they
were left out of ryan johnson's
follow-up because he couldn't find a
place for them in the movie
according to vanity fair's lev grossman
however the rise of skywalker is going
to finally provide
some answers about the mysterious gang
fans got their first look at these
so-called elite fearsome enforcers of
kylo ren's dark well
in annie lieberman's extensive photo
shoot and what's immediately clear is
that they're not your typical star wars
villains
in contrast to the sleek and shiny look
adopted by the first order
and the galactic empire before it the
knights of ren wear dirty ragtag armor
and carry over-the-top weapons
vanity fair's joanna robinson wrote
their diy look including one especially
lethal looking gun arm would be equally
at home in one of the mad max movies
their identities have not yet been
revealed though fans think they have a
pretty good idea about where they came
from
in the last jedi luke reveals that kylo
vanished with a handful of his padawan
learners when he set the temple ablaze
and turned his back on the jedi did
luke's former students become the
knights of ren
now that the emperor's involvement and
the rise of skywalker has been confirmed
it's safe to assume that he'll be
involved in the film's final battle
who where and how he'll be battling
isn't really certain but according to
making star wars editor jason ward
there's a huge rumor during the rounds
that pits kylo ren against palpatine
in the form of matt smith the british
actor has been telling journalists that
he isn't in episode 9 but that's a claim
that runs contrary to many reports about
the movie
even international disney websites are
listing the former doctor who star as
being among the cursed
and jason ward believes that he'll be
playing a critical role ward reported a
really solid source over the years
passed on something they heard
internally the rumor is that matt smith
isn't palpatine reborn or rejuvenated
but a dark side acolyte
during the final act of the film rey and
kylo team up to fight the palpatine
possessed
matt smith ward's inside source claims
that kylo ren is possessed by the
emperor after killing his host body
leading to one last moment of redemption
the tormented son of han solo and leia
organa has enough light left in him to
lay down his arm so rey can finish the
job
becoming ben solo again in his final
moments with kylo ren dead and rey being
apparently too pure of a person for the
emperor to possess
the fight against palpatine is one at
last luke skywalker vanishes after
helping leia and what's left of the
resistance escape at the end of the last
jedi
passing on peacefully into the force it
was a highly divisive moment for fans
and one that director ryan johnson was
forced to defend as the backlash grew
johnson reminded everyone that we may
not have seen the last of skywalker
he told variety i don't know where the
next movie is going to go but it seemed
like the potential of luke crossing into
a new realm
that offers exciting possibilities for
the role he plays in the coming chapter
yoda returned as a force ghost in the
last jedi and rumors that skywalker will
do the same in the upcoming sequel
have been around for some time now in
2018 pinewood insiders claimed that sets
were being erected for two episode nine
scenes involving mark hamill
an express source claimed this may well
indicate that luke will appear as a
force goes to kylo ren
and race separately thanks to hamel
himself this rumor can now be classified
as a spoiler the actor has since
confirmed he's appearing as a force
ghost in the rise of skywalker in june
2019 he told the associated press
the fact that i'm involved in any
capacity is only because of that
peculiar aspect of the star wars
mythology in that as a jedi you're
allowed to come back and make a curtain
call as a force ghost
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one